this is the kind of question we've been
doing most recently what are these
objects called
the two things I gave you they are what
are the different denominator which
means they're fractions but the only are
they fractions what's on the numerators
there's printed rules so that's why we
call these algebraic fractions let's
kind of look what is this first line
doing what is it accomplishing that
helps us get toward the goal we're
getting a common denominator right just
like any other fraction it's just that
there's algebra to the mix do you agree
with the way that the colored diamonds
have been created you happy with 12 good
choice it is it's as small as you can
get they'll get both of them in we've
multiplied this one over here the first
one by 3 over 3
yes and then this one by 4 over 4 just
check out another bit here
what is this pie to go ok so these two
fractions but you actually can't combine
them because they're the color
denominator Tom did you include the
content nobody ok that's right he came
back at the end but you get it I was
like last time was the fun food what one
simple trick this one's from we have we
have certified the way we did it was we
collected like terms
totally 2008 a Tegra 3 a 7 9 take away
20 big of them happy or not
sup all right have a look at this one
now it's interesting because what you
end up with because they're different we
insert er is quite a bit of mess not
much that simplifies out so does where
did this come from
every 5 company guys right what I'm 10
or 2 went that's all I don't see any
root 2 in the question so where did we
choose till you come summer
okay good so you can see how this is the
first thing could she did just excellent
the next thing she did was she just kept
on going along with a good chunk of it
which is really written the answered but
if you did the working for this to root
5 times root 10 is 250 do you agree that
it's been a little while since of it sir
but then you can decently with this
right we could get what you pull out 50
the biggest square number if it's in
that is 25 so we can pull out root 25
right but I can encourage you to think
that let's say in your head take every 5
you're checking out the original 25
there's a very common error to make
under pretty good pressure okay rich 25
of course is by which is why 2 times 5
is 10 so that doesn't take away 4 looks
good take away root 10 and you're done
okay right last time I there's literally
Dundas like a textbook would do it okay
he set it out every single line is there
maybe you put a not as many lines as
this or maybe something from your
solution is missing that Leo Scott what
have you done
third line well crazy is added 4 to both
sides because he wants to why is that
like wide area for both sides actually
progress it kisses the minus 4 but why
what's wrong with the minus 4 like who's
the problem with having of their that's
the plot for the other side why is the
second line better than the first one
now it is simpler but only for a
particular agent I'm going to say it
again I said it yesterday I'm going to
avoid say the word simple or simplify
because it's what you say when either
you don't want to tell the other person
like we do the test what to do or you
don't know what actually has been
accomplished because simpler can be
anything right
it's like saying something's good
there's a descriptive quality to that ok
so here the reason why is better is
because when you're asked to solve
something right what we want is for X
whatever Protea you've gotten there to
be the subject we want x equals at the
end well this negative falls in the way
getting from here to here is progress
because now I have x squared on tone
that'll help you get X on its own does
that make sense you've got to know a
direction for why you're doing this not
just sort of mindlessly moving symbols
around what's he done from line tune
Olympic do you see yeah go ahead waiting
on okay so there is a square here he's
actually put it under the square though
right so he's done what's the opposite
got when he's on the square root but
very cleverly he's got this part here
why is that there yeah yeah but both the
negative ones the positive ones will
work in this life right so he leave that
fossilized there and sure enough if you
put in plug to it which I think most
people got that's true 2 squared minus 4
is 0 but negative 2 negative 2 all
squared minus 4 is still 0 it sort
what's also solutions you've got to have
this one we've seen this with